[Music]
just
spectacular okay everybody you know it's
time to get together and go through the
collection again it's been such a long
time and so many changes have occurred
in my collection lots of new entrance
lots of new dial ideas lots of new
concepts of Manufacturers fantastic new
brands have emerged on the market new
Independence let's go through all of it
so I'm on the road and I like to travel
with between 17 and 20 pieces now that's
not easy to do you have to arrange
security all that stuff but these days
I'm going double wristed why am I doing
that because of the confusion in time
zones this is New York this is LA and
people say well why don't you just
subtract 3 hours what why do that when
you could put two watches on what are
you kidding oh look La it's quarter to
three oh New York it's quar to
six what a great idea plus you're
showcasing your pieces that's fantastic
that's the whole idea so let's go
through the colle some new Concepts here
first of all I'm going to go randomly
through here just as I feel um some new
ideas before we end today I have to tell
you about a new project I've got one of
the biggest challenges I have is how do
I ensure these watches these are
traveling with me a dozen here and two
here right 14 watches but I only want to
ensure them while they're on the road
they're going to be on the road for 10
days that's why I created Wonder
care.com
check it out it's going to light up in
January but you can go to wonder care
right now and register it will allow you
to take a photograph of your watch with
your phone and ensure it it'll cost
about 1 and a half% of either the
replacement value or the purchase price
you decide what you want to insure it
for how long you want to insure it you
just want to insure it for a day no
problem you want to insure it for a week
no problem I love that it finally solves
for me I created Wonder care.com to
solve for my collection as it travels
all around the world now this starts in
the US us only check out Wonder
care.com I mean thank goodness for
Wonder care because now I can ensure
just what I want to I don't want to
ensure watches that are sitting in a
vault under a bank but this every one of
these are insured while they're on the
road Wonder care.com I said it again
Shameless promotion check it out the
first Trend that has really emerged cuz
I'm in LA right now but just got in from
myami you know go to Vegas quite often
New York I would say even just 5 years
ago you would not see a lot of men
wearing a lot of bling that's all
changed if you look at the new pieces
like take Rolex for example take even
PCH Philip anybody they're blinging it
out and why is that because guys like to
be flashy and they like to be trashy and
that's where you go with an eye of the
tiger ich waah it doesn't get any
flashier or trashier you can't even read
the time on this you need sunglasses
there's so many diamonds on this thing
but it is beautiful and it's so well
crafted I mean the work that Rolex does
with Jewelers and of course the time
pieces are amazing and as always the Red
Band this is my Shark Tank box right
here practically everything has a red
band on it with the exception of two
pieces we'll talk about so I the tiger
Ichi waak Kara now when I go double
fisted with this watch I match it up
with the LA time oh yeah
baby the rainbow now why is the rainbow
you know 10 years ago you could walk
into a Rolex deal and buy one of these
forget about it now not a chance not a
chance the waiting list for this is
years because all the guys in sports
whether you're baseball or hockey or
basketball they got to have one of these
pieces now this is a beautiful rose gold
rainbow and you know the whole idea of
the rainbow is a jewelry representing
all the different colors of light it's
beautiful now when you go I the Tiger on
the left New York time and
Rainbow on the right with LA
time I've seen grown men weep I'm not
kidding grown men weep in the presence
of these two watches together it's
stereo baby that's what I'm talking
about flashy trashy flashy trashy flashy
trashy totally La total Miami and when
the F1 hits in Vegas yeah baby now you
can't be walking around the streets with
these not today security is just too
nuts and places like San Francisco
Unfortunately they turned into war zones
I don't even wear watching San Francisco
I don't even go to San Francisco they
got to fix that place you can't even
wear you can't even walk there let alone
wear a watch you'll be executed
immediately city is so poorly managed
but I don't want to get into Politics on
a watch YouTube come on all right but
before we leave the whole idea of P
remember protect Philip so
conservative and then they come out with
the
loose
this is their version of a rainbow it's
just beautiful and by the way that red
band that red band that's Factory which
means they made it for Mr Wonderful why
else would they send to North America a
red band pek it's Mr Wonderful for sure
now when I saw the rumor of this watch I
immediately started making calls saying
if there anybody has waited forever for
a factory Red Band on a pect phip it's
got to be me and there you have it
now the reason I bring that up is let's
take a classic this is the
pek Genta design steel thin now
legendary why they stopped making it
another watch grown men weep for the
blue dial so historic the clean look of
5711 there's also a version of this that
Tiffany puts a stamp on that sells for
Millions it's the same watch though it's
the 5711 now you cannot put a red band
on this so I never wear it on Shark Tank
I never wear it on TV but I do put it on
my right hand for La time and it's a
beautiful piece a 5711 you can recognize
it 20 yards away in a room when I see a
5711 I nod my head to the person who's
wearing it lots of women like the 5711
too but a great travel piece a wonderful
watch a beautiful gentes
design just love it and of course you
know never going to have red band on it
let's move on the video that I first
showed this piece
in where I start to cry that was real
those were not crocodile tears this is a
one-of-a-kind AP open Works yep a Royal
Oak covered in rubies with a red band
the only one in the world with a red
band you know why this is a shark tank
piece I don't wear this out ever really
I just use it on Shark Tank but my
goodness it is so beautiful this piece
so stunning so so
spectacular what a dial you know I
almost want to cry right now again
that's that's the problem with this
thing it's so you know this whole idea
of of you think about open dials and
open works and skeleton
watches this is a new phenomenon this is
not you didn't find a lot of this 50
years ago people when they first saw
them said that looks weird what's the
matter with that watch but now you can
see the beauty of the actual makers work
and I think that's what make makes a
watch like this so spectacular so screw
down
crown and just watching the movement
itself and of course this is a custom
red minute sweep you'll never see that
in AP you see it here
beautiful all right where else where do
we go next
oh something I'm wearing on my wrist 3
weeks ago I was in Tokyo now I don't
know if you've heard about Grand SEO
they make some of the best watches on
Earth and certainly the best value if
you're starting your collection and you
want incredible technology incredible
accuracy Beauty in terms of the Polish
of the metal you got to go with gr SEO
but there's a brand it's part of the
group it's called credor now why is
credor so
famous this is a platinum polished
credor a blue dial now the reason credor
has made collectors just rule for their
pieces and they make so few of them is
the hand painted enamel the Japanese
Masters who do this in the case of this
blue dial when you see the close-up of
this you're going to see The Edge looks
luminescent but it's not a luminescent
watch there's no radioactive paint here
there's no back lighting so what's going
on how did they do it they started with
a cream white anamel hand painted just
meticulously takes forever to do this
then they started layering on the blue
but on the edges near where the
actual you know CR the the dial meets
the case they left a little less blue so
that the white sha through and that
gives it that phenomenon of
luminescence you know when I saw this in
Tokyo 3 weeks ago I said I have to buy
it they said I'm sorry there's only one
here it's been put on reserve by a
Japanese collector so I immediately Med
went out of my mind and said look let me
buy the piece I'm a collector I already
have a credor I was very fortunate I
called up Bryce the head of the grand
SEO in the United States and luckily he
was able to acquire one for me here it
is I've only had this watch a few days
but that's why I'm doing this video to
show you some new
Pieces Just spectacular I mean and I
mean I'm here in La for actually Grand
SEO events so I'm wearing that today I'm
doing a panel about dials and while
we're at it this is a new dial now this
is steel and by the way Grand SEO does
an amazing job polishing steel they do
an amazing job polishing steel there's
nobody like it this sparkle that you see
again with the only one with a red band
This is called the katana limited
edition sold only in American Boutique
so if you're looking for a spectacular
watch sub 10,000 this is it and now that
you've heard about it from me first
before they sell them all out try and
get one of these because you have never
seen and by the way when you dial you
wind this thing the crunch is it's it's
I won't say Beyond protect but you know
what I'm saying I mean and these are
these spring this is so these spring
drives are so accurate so accurate it's
incredible this thing keeps time like
your phone does and it's a mechanical
watch
beautiful all right we've got six more
we're going into the land of Jor now fpj
is an
independent um that came rocking on the
scene the watches have gone up like
crazy since we last met this is my new
Jor again it's always the dials that
make it so interesting when Jordan makes
a watch there's nothing like it I mean
you can recognize this from across the
room that is a Jor this has a red band
on it it's my brand new piece in the
collection
beautiful you know it's so simple yet
clean so recognizable as a urine I knew
you'd love it power Reserve is almost as
large as the actual minute hand it's
really a beautiful
thing all right while we're talking
joran this is number six of the New York
Boutique cograph what's unique about
this piece well first of all it's one of
10 there'll never be more for the New
York Boutique and it's also measures by
the hundredth of a second which is so
incredible you think about a a watch
that can do that and how complex the
technology is that does that but this is
what this watch does and that's what's
made it so famous absolutely
stunning I love
it anyways you know another amazing dial
and also great for the
road okay an all time classic and we're
going to go two in a row steel white
face Daytona probably the most sought
after watch in the world this one has a
red band on it cuz I wore it on Shark
Tank season 15 beautiful classic I mean
there were years and years ago you this
was a watch that Rolex couldn't give
away now it's the most coveted design in
Rolex all around the world people love
this piece while we're talking about it
they brought out a series they've
discontinued now called the meteorite I
did this one in Gold but look at that
this dial is actually a shaved piece of
meteorite
so it came from the planet Rolex fell to
Earth and Rolex
shaved these dials until they ran out of
meteorite we're going to have to wait
for another rock to come from the planet
Rolex to do these again also beautiful
but you know thinking about left wrist
right wrist stereo
Daytona that's an
ichara ying and yang New York
La you get it double red bands on this
one two unique pieces but both Rolex
daytonas absolutely gorgeous all right
just a couple left back to Jour on the
chronometer blue now this was their
entry level watch or one of them okay
you'll wait years for one of these now
why cuz there's a rumor that Putin wears
it these dials as tantalum is the case
is the metal but the blue dial is so
difficult to make that 66 % are rejected
so that's why it's so hard to get one of
these you know Jan's a perfectionist now
a little story
about this piece I mean I love it cuz
it's so simple so beautiful and it
reflects differently in different
elements of light now I said entry level
forj but the actual original entry level
was the elegant this is a quartz watch
what's unique about it is you never have
to change the battery in your whole life
because it has a mode that goes to sleep
you put it down on the table 20 minutes
later it's using tiny just a couple of
microns of electricity to remember the
time you could leave it for a year and
pick it up and it goes back to where it
left off keeps perfect time it's amazing
piece now this is a quartz watch so I
said to FP Jordan and to P the CEO of
the Americas why don't you've got demand
for 20 30 40,000 of these watches it
used to be a $177,000 watch it's way
more than that now but why don't you
Mass produce this to let people get at
least one Jord in their collection
because they can't even get this anymore
the waiting list is 2 years or even
longer and I expressed that in a serious
conversation with FP himself and he
looked at me and said
[Laughter]
no yeah you know that's the thing about
fpj he's running the show and he just
says no so these things are just as rare
as every other Jordan one of my favorite
watches by the way I just love the
design I love the look of it it's just
so beautiful and my wife has one with
PVE diamonds she she calls it her
favorite watch now just absolutely
beautiful
the elegant and last on the Hit Parade
you probably noticed that on my La time
right here are you ready one of my
latest Acquisitions this is an
ichihuahua moment Mr Wonderful here and
there's no debate about this small
businesses in America create over 60% of
the jobs but times are tough is there a
solution yes the government employee
retention credit program go to wonder
trust.com today is that a puzzle yes it
is is the Rolex puzzle there's only
three of them known in North America
right now here's the story all right now
first of all when I heard about this
watch and I saw the videos I thought it
was aibs I thought it was some kind of
April Fool's joke Rolex would never make
a watch like this with no day on it no
date and just emojis and little sayings
like peace and Harmony no way they would
do that that's not Rolex they're too
conservative when I heard this was real
I went out of my mind like every other
collector did all around the world world
everybody wants a puzzle so the rumor
for North
America's yep John Mayor got the white
gold all right Brady the famous
quarterback now may is a musician Brady
is of course world famous quarterback
he's got the rose gold and this is the
yellow gold Rolex is brilliant they gave
one to an entrepreneur investor that's
me Sports guy who's got millions of
followers mayor's got millions of
followers we all have millions of
followers and we're having fun on social
media with this this this is bringing in
the new generation of funloving Rolex
collectors I think that was what they're
thinking about watching wonders last
year this thing got announced the
world's gone crazy for this they'll make
more but who knows when and where
they're going to show up the demand in
Asia is insatiable now I would not put a
red band on this obviously because the
presidential bracelet is so beautiful
and it is my La watch today so on the
left the credor Amazing Blue dial on the
right the
puzzle let's check the time oh it's 2
minutes after 6:00 in New York I wonder
what time it is in
la oh it's 2 minutes after 3 thank
goodness I've got a credor in the puzzle
from Rolex now if I have to worry about
the time in Abu Dhabi I'm going to have
to put one on my left ankle which I'm
going to do soon this is how you get to
four watches you never get lost on time
that's the answer I'm glad you joined me
today there's so much to talk about in
watch this but this is just the basics I
will see you soon oh my little baby's
here just love it now these are going
back into the Vault now Talk Amongst
yourselves I'll see you again soon bye
everybody